série j'ai envie de jouer un petit jeu
avec vous puisque on va se faire un
c'est leur choix c'est très simple on a
demandé à chacun des chroniqueurs de
nous raconter la plus grosse rigolade
qui leur est arrivé la plus grosse
galère mais cette fois-ci evelyne ce
sera toi de deviner à qui appartient le
dossier d'accord moi je mets tout sur
papier on a une loi j'ai simulé un
malaise pour ne pas foirer mon plan
drague à ton avis qui a fait ça autour
de la table ma fille ma fille non c'est
pas ma fille c'est ludivine nette hausse
j'ai rien dit mais c'est moi que tu as
fait et je me suis fait embarquer par
les pompiers mais c'était tout mais
raconte l'histoire
j'arrive en soirée il ya monde et est si
belle comme le château il ya dix ans je
t'aime ainsi été très très belle
toujours très belle non mais oui mais
beaucoup moins - mince qu'à l'époque un
décor de calogero le chroniqueur comme
avant son mec c'est le garde du corps de
kenji winona avant l'été avec elle a
fait que des gardes du corps s'est fait
qu'à un moment elle ressort elle était
de garde et vous savez quoi et il
pleuvait et tout donc c'est un peu
mouillé sur le sol j'arrive en talons et
quand je tape ma meilleure démarche je
glisse et je ne fracasse sur le sol et
tout le monde me regarde et là je fais
comme si j'étais inconsciente oui j'ai
reçu leur sueur mais pour amoureux ou ne
pas voir la rentrée exactement pourquoi
vers l'arrière devant monde et les
pompiers sont venus me chercher je vous
assure un brancard et ou alors j'ai été
cité dans un faites entrer l'accusé
moi j'aurais à tout prix marie larry est
normal
[Rires]
cela nous a dit me dit mitchell aurait
alors non je crois que son mari je sais
pas qui c'est mais c'est toi c'est très
le nom je sais pourquoi c'est comme ma
soeur on sortait aux bananes avec pascal
sellem jean marie bigard ya eu la grande
époque du banana où il y avait des
délires en terrasse
c'était l'endroit le plus sympa de paris
nous était assassiné ravaillac
oui non mais ravaillac après avoir tué
henri iv il s'est réfugié dans la cave
du banana café emballé et donc avec guy
georges qui étaient là voilà toi je
n'étais pas loin
c'est dans ce genre d'endroit tu vois un
mec tu leur voix la semaine d'après je
te dis bonjour
hélas après laffaire explose et
j'appelle présence hellemmes jeudi
pascal j'ai pas rêver guy georges c'est
bien le mec qui nous disait bonjour au
banana café et un jour il ya fait entrer
l'accusé et 10 le banana café un endroit
de prise et de groot celle abriter
regarde à tuléar la route le club
rencontre et presque aussitôt le succès
est devenue la boîte des stars sur palma
billard et laurent baffie c'était
vraiment les jeux qui s'y tient en
permanence garde faites entrer l'accusé
sinon je ne peux pas déféquer sur me
mettre entièrement nue joker qui est
assez vous ça ça c'est max a annoncé
inavouables le pire c'est que cc c'est
un toc d'anvers que je ne peux pas aller
yaiche 100 m
[Rires]
j'ai ça depuis que je suis tout petit
vos témoignages
je me suis déjà fait caresser par un
fantôme j'ai parlé un tendon ou c'est un
jeu qui ne satisfait ni je suis parti
voir un médecin pour ça parce que j'ai
cru que j'avais des hallucinations il
m'a dit que c'était peut-être de la
paralysie du sommeil pas un instant j
crois d'abord senti des caresses dans
mes cheveux et là je vous assure ça
comment les filles vous courrez ça me
glace le sang et puis maintenant voilà
qui me caresse les jambes c'est sûr ils
sont hélas non là bas je me caresse les
cheveux les jambes il très santé la
cuisse est vraiment bien la cuisson est
donc la dernière chose en date
j'ai senti les mains comme ça ça me
tenait c'est là où il me dit c'est une
paralysie du sommeil et de quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
macho possible à ce poste et j'ai déjà
entendu su sauter mon prénom
il disait de tiffany fans ici
[Applaudissements]
allez tiens j'ai fait la couverture de
romans photos pornos fabien lecoeuvre
c'est vous ouais c'est moi ouais c'était
non j'étais étudiante parce que le
secrétaire brigitte bardot m'avait
m'avait mis en rapport avec un mec qui
faisait du roman-photo chais pas que
c'est dur pour faute aux adultes minutes
est tenue à oui biensur avec ce corps
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des photos choc après cette fois les
choix faisait de l'argent de poche avait
trouvé cette combine qui était pas mal
j'en ai fait 117 par fabien lecoeuvre a
fait plus de couverture porno que clara
morgane mais ça va me dire ils ont fait
chier pour 5,6 me
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai eu une relation avec cyril hanouna
est bon mais c'est toi le public
clara en année on a les images d'un
ballon mais pardon ah bon bien entendu
c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est pas du
tout on a des images c'est une caméra
cachée qu'on avait fait un ami je lui ai
fait croire qu'on était ensemble clara
et moi et regarder je crois que c'est
plus ton ami depuis non mais s'il se
voie publique ne regardez regardez je
teste un ami aujourd'hui je vais tester
ça me c'est très simple ça fait un mois
qui croient que je sors avec clara
morgane un dock il croit qu'elle est
folle de moi je suis fou des louis arki
fingers quoi hélas ce qu'elle va faire
c'est qu'elle va venir dans ce bureau
elle va le chauffe les mets à bloc
pendant une heure à les acheter mais il
a dit qu'il n'est pas loin d'être un bon
ça va c'est que c'est un [ __ ]
[Musique]
selon cui alentours
tu veux essayer danic et fatima l'aneth
et atuge tu croyais que c'etait pas
sérieux mais mon frein tu présentes au
pain mais tout je te semble pas très
malin normalement il est à revoir exact
mais merde sur le bois les tenir mais tu
présentes dans la vérité et non
franchement franchement démerde guetta
caméra cachée bien entendu je vous
rappel c'est comme ma soeur oui c'est un
beau me sens dans la vraie vie des ossis
non
[Rires]